Several years ago,
the World Health Organization declared
that it wasn't cost effective to help
people get treatment for drug resistant
tuberculosis,
and there was an organization called
partners in health that said simply
refused six up this claim.
They said,
we're going to do whatever it takes to
help these people.
So they came up with a program for
treating drug resistant tuberculosis in
some of the world's most conflict ridden
poorest places,
and they succeeded in doing it.
They had very good treatment outcomes,
so they thought creatively about how to
come up with treatment programs that
worked,
and as a result,
funding for drug resistant TB increased
spectacularly.
And now many people around the world
have treatment.
So what do they do?
I think what they did is they have this
virtue which requires three things.
First that we commit to fulfilling human
rights.
Second,
that we think creatively or imagine ways
of doing that,
and finally that we act to do so.
So let me explain the virtue of creative
resolve a little bit more and hopefully
you'll see why I think it's really
important.
So first,
to have the virtue,
one has to question evidence against the
possibility of fulfilling human rights.
We can do this in many ways so we can
question the source reliability or
implications of that evidence.
It's possible,
um,
to acquiesce to quickly in the face of
evidence that it's impossible to help
people or to be so pigheaded that we
refuse to accept the constraints so they
give it.
The second thing that we need to do is I
think consider all of the options on the
table and then use our imagination to
come up with new options.
Finally,
we should act to fulfill human rights
and this requires a measure of grit will
or resoluteness.
We can't be inflexible and persists even
when it is actually impossible to
fulfill rights,
but at the same time we shouldn't be
complacent about it.
Since change is difficult,
people who don't think that it's
possible or desirable to fulfill human
rights probably won't try hard to do so.
So hope is important for the virtue of
creative resolve.
Hope is simply believing something that
one desires as possible,
but not certain.
Still,
even when we lack a kind of hope,
I think we should have the virtue of
creative resolve as long as there is not
conclusive evidence that fulfilling
human rights is impossible.
So the kind of hope we need is a radical
hope in the face of uncertainty.
We must persist and exercise our moral
imaginations to help people meet their
basic needs.
But the reason we should have creative
resolve is this.
The ground for the human rights is
protecting everybody's ability to live a
human life.
And it's really important that we do
that.
So we should try hard.
I think the imperative to try hard is
particularly compelling given that
there's a lot of psychological evidence
that people don't try hard enough.
They tend to search to,
to uh,
not far enough for solutions to
problems.
And many people seem to have a narrow
view of possibility and feasibility.
Assuming tight timeframes and financial
constraints when we imagine ourselves
succeeding and tasks were often more
likely to do so.
Perhaps because our imagination as a
sense of agency and lets us set plans
for the future and act to achieve them.
The crux of my disagreement with critics
of the human right to health who think
we have to ration and that the human
right has to tell us how to do that is
this.
I don't think that's what the human
rights health has to do,
or even that it should rather.
I think it does something much more
important for us.
I think it inspires us to do our best to
help everyone meet their basic needs.
Okay.
But if we do have to ration,
here's what I think.
I think creative resolve can help us do
that.
I think it can help us find better ways
of helping more people.
We can't simply build hospitals in the
city rather than also in the countryside
because it's most cost effective to do
that.
Everybody has a human right to health
and if we think creatively enough about
how to do it,
we may be able to help everybody.
Okay,
so there's two sides to this virtue.
On the one side,
we should try very hard to help people
fulfill their human rights.
On the other side,
we don't have to try when it's
impossible or impermissible to do that,
but I'm going to stress and I have been
stressing the positive or commitment
side of the virtue.
For this reason,
millions of people around the world are
suffering and dying every year from
poverty related causes,
and it's not as if there's millions of
people trying to help them.
I believe we need to try harder,
try harder,
try harder.
I think we need to find both the
resources and the political will to do
this
and like Martin Luther King,
we should refuse to believe that the
bank of justice.